[Music]
they called me big head
one day that big beautiful wound
wrecking head of yours is going to
change the world
time to change the world by bringing it
to its
knees attack the future is modoc
and do you know what modok stands for
mental organism designs only
[Music]
where does he go at night nobody knows
oh no one took the cans out come on
ah [ __ ] we have to tell the kids
about us kids she's lost her mind you
have to stop
what are you telling the kids i'm
comforting them and if you tell her i
said any of this this will be one of the
many divorces where it
is the kid's fault
i'm wonder man pending avenger underwear
model and lover of your wife this is an
outrageous
i shall reclaim my family i should
reclaim my destiny
iron man chief shot to the back of the
head i know but i was actually aiming
for literally any other part of your
[Music]
body
[Music]
[Music]
am i good businessman uh yeah about that
we're bankrupt what
i'm sorry i thought this coffee was for
[Music]
everyone
[Music]
you